the Battle of a person was a political
victory for Ukraine but it wasn't the
military victory that everybody was
hoping it would be
Southern Port City of person is vital
for both Ukraine and for Russia Russia
took her son in the opening days of the
invasion literally in that sweep that
lightning sweep right across the south
of Ukraine so Hustler's been in Russian
hands all the way until last week very
near the city of person is the dam the
dam we've all heard about has been hit
and novakovica that is the passage that
is the entry point for the freshwater
Canal that feeds the all of the Crimean
so it's absolutely vitals whoever owns
it controls what's going on in Crimean
so they have been pointing it out
Ukraine does believe that it is making
significant advances in her son
is
the Russians didn't Panic the Russians
retreated in good order the Russians
didn't they didn't surrender on mass
which would have been an utter debacle
and would have probably ended the war
but it made the Ukraine made the
ukrainians wear it they suddenly thought
I'm going to take care everyone's
retreating a little too calmly a little
too easily let's not rush in guys and to
take everything because we could be
walking right into a trap here uh it
turns out that they weren't but now the
Russians have retreated to carefully
prepared positions on the near side of
the NEPA River and they fortified
themselves but it wasn't quite the
military victory that everybody thought
it was going to be that the Russian
forces were totally destroyed they
weren't destroyed they just moved they
just moved back
foreign
now this next phase is really going to
be one of the defining battles of the
Ukrainian War so I think what President
Putin is trying to do is just basically
make ukrainians fight for every single
centimeter of land now and that's going
to be the issues to make it really
really hard for them and keep retreating
back but very very very slowly so in the
hope that the ukrainians do eventually
exhaust themselves and come to the
negotiating table and something I think
they would only do ukrainians would only
do if they were absolutely flat out
defeated and that's a long way to come
the coming battle now for this area
Ukraine and Russia will have to fight
for in the coming winter of the neck of
the Crimean Peninsula is going to be one
of the defining battles of this war